فيديو كليما
عد الى افريقيا هذه الجمله كانت كافيه
تنذيذ كاي جدوى جدا بشان العنصريه في
فرنسا
[تصفيق]
جاءت شراره هذه النوبه الجديده من تحت قبه
البرلمان حين قطع نائب من اقصى اليمين
زميلا له من اصول افريقيه كان النائب
كارلوس مارتينز بيلونجو عن حزب فرنسا
الابيه اليسرى يتساءل عن خطط الحكومه
لمساعده المهاجرين القادمين من افريقيا
على مواجهه المخاطر في عرض البحر اثناء
رحله العبور الطويله الى اوروبا فجاه صح
النائب فرناس
المتهمين التجمع الوطني فليعد الى افريقيا
استنكار عارما في القاعه وموجه اخرى من
الجدل خارجها رئاسه جمعيه الوطنيه
الفرنسيه اعتبرت ما قاله النائب اليمني ذا
حموله عنصريه وقررت معاقبته بالمنع من
دخول مقر البرلمان مده 15 يوما وهو قرار
صوته عليه الكتل البرلمانيه كلها باستثناء
كتله التجمع الوطني
في تغريده له على تويتر وصف النائب ديف
فرناس القراره بالظالم في حقه وبانه
مصادره لحريه الراي وازارته في ذلك رئيسه
الحزب مارين لوبان
جدل جديد قديم تفجر اذا في بلد شعاره
الحريه والمساواه والاخوه في وقفه مناهضه
للعنصريه وداعمه الله اعتبر النائب
بيلونجو ان ما جاعد لسان النائب اليمني
اساءه لملايين الفرنسيين
[تصفيق]